hey 42 here it is possible to win a game
of chess in just two moves welcome to
RIF a reservoir water was discovered 400
miles beneath the earth's surface that
contains three times as much water as
all of the oceans put together the
number of Crayola colors available
doubles every 28 years during the
California Gold Rush water cost more
than gold Charles Darwin's last book was
called the formation of vegetable mould
through the action of worms when he
enlisted in the Army j.r.r tolkien son
Michael cut down his father's profession
as wizard if Bill Gates gave his entire
fortune to the US government it would
only cover the national deficit for
fifteen days one in ten
Icelanders will publish a book at some
time in their life Paganini was the
fastest violinist ever he was recorded
playing 12 notes per second spraying
dirty clothes with vodka makes them
smell better because vodka kills the
odor causing bacteria the world's oldest
robot is one thousand years old the
hairy frog often called the horror frog
has a unique defense system when
threatened
it breaks the bones in its toes and
forces them through its skin to create
claws the Lord of the Rings holds the
record for the greatest number of false
feet used in a single movie sixty
thousand there are currently 1397 known
asteroids capable of causing major
devastation if they hit the earth there
are 177 thousand one hundred and
forty-seven ways to tie a tie a group of
hackers once tucked down Papa John's
website because their pizza was laid
thanks for the view subscribe for more
forty-two